foreign
now I wanted to include this when I did
the she shed I made an announcement that
Bex well I finally got rid of my storage
shed that I was paying for for my wife
and
um Matt we we've actually put a shed in
our backyard I think TK wasn't here for
that no yeah no he wasn't uh we did
every week we do a home tour on the
podcast and uh we built a shed in our
backyard so we could get rid of our
storage unit the hell bex's camping gear
now why do we have a storage unit is
because I did not want to have camping
gear strewn throughout our house or just
in our bedroom somewhere or in our
closet and so we decided the best use of
our money at the time until we could
afford to buy a shed was to pay 80 bucks
a month for a storage locker for a
temporary period of time not that the
stuff was going to sit in there in
perpetuity however what Cheryl was
saying is she had storage locker for a a
long period of time can we read her
comment yes she said that she wanted to
share an excerpt from a Blog she posted
in regards to that experience quote then
came the math over the course of that
time period from January 2006 through
April 2015 I had spent a staggering 6
780.15 to store my useless things that's
right I paid nearly seven thousand
dollars for someone to hold on to things
I didn't even want or need as painful as
it was to see that figure it was behind
me a mistake I won't repeat on the
bright side had I not confronted the
storage unit when I did I would have
gone on to spend an additional seven
thousand four hundred and forty dollars
through today 93 months at eighty
dollars per month which is what it cost
when I left there however I'm sure
they've raised that price so it could be
closer to eight thousand thinking about
it that way thank goodness I took care
of it when I did sure I lost seven
thousand dollars but by finally
confronting the stuff most of which I
had no use for by the way I'm saving
thousands more what a relief
okay isn't this a metaphor in some ways
we often pay for things
that cease to give us value or maybe
they give us value even for a period of
time but we keep paying for it yes we
pay money seven thousand dollars we pay
with for it though with energy with
attention with time with our skills and
it eats Us Alive slowly over a
protracted period of time yeah and we're
paying for a narrative
and the right to hold on to that
narrative because when you say goodbye
to that stuff and just give it away or
just recycle it well it's over now
there's no story to tell yourself about
it other than this is what it meant to
me when I bought it and this is what I
did with it after it ceased to be useful
but you pay that storage fee it's not
just for somebody to hold on to your
stuff it's for you to hold on to the
story of one day one day I might
and the price of one day I might is so
much more than just the money you give
to the storage facility it's also the
the Mind share and the Creative Energy
that you take away from the now moment
and all of the joy that you could be
experiencing in this now moment because
it's similar to procrastination right
where what you are choosing is not a
life of comfort but a life in which you
try to see how much enjoyment and fun
can I have while being haunted by this
ghost Hmm this is a ghost that says you
know you gotta pay for that right you
know this is gonna come back to haunt
you right
have you ever heard of a she shed before
TK no yeah me either I'm from Chicago I
don't even know if that it's funny
because like it's it's like uh we'll
explain what why is it a she shed well
it's actually not a she shed but my
wife's is just a shed I jokingly called
it a she shed yeah it's the female
equivalent of a man cave and so like
often what'll happen is if you want like
some sort of crafts area you would call
it a man cave for men where you like you
do your manly things right and where
women do their womenly things it's used
the term is she shed right oh I think I
just call it the house
I just call it going home
I think I think what we do now is we use
both of these terms pejoratively I
actually don't have a man cave or a she
shed at home we just have a regular shed
yeah I keep a broom in there and Bex
keeps everything else in there that
broom is cathartic though yeah I bet no
it's funny because I've never heard of
that term either until he brought it up
I'm like what the heck is that she shed
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free